these gurus have a huge conflict of
interest because most of them want to
sell you information so they want to
convince you they have a vested interest
in convincing you that the Amazon
opportunity is this incredible thing and
you can make you know anybody can do it
and whatever or whatever and it's just
not true I have none of that vested
interest so I feel like I'm a pretty
unbiased party so what does the Amazon
income opportunity actually look like
well let's go through it so there's this
great website called market pulse where
they do Amazon analytics and they put
together this great sheet that basically
shows you how much people are making so
there are six million sellers on Amazon
including the inactive ones they
estimate that there's probably 2.5
million active sellers with products for
sale so people who are trying to do it
this would be you of those 2.5 million
only 200 thousand of them will be making
a hundred thousand dollars in sales this
year now you might be thinking to
yourself well 200,000 out of 2.5 million
isn't a lot but you know $100,000 in
sales that sounds pretty good well this
is the problem
sales revenue doesn't equal profit sales
revenue really couldn't matter less
profit is what you take home it's the
part that you keep after expenses for
product paid advertising you know reap
market research this gets whittled down
to anywhere between 10 to 25% of that
that's your profit margin people often
overestimate how much they're gonna make
in profit margin I would say a
conservative estimate being on the
conservative side let's say you're
making a 15% profit margin that means
that out of that $100,000 in sales the
exceptional people on amazon selling
third party are making roughly fifteen
thousand dollars a year to put that into
context that's about the salary of a
full-time McDonald's employee but
McDonald's guarantees they will make
that Amazon there's no guarantee in fact
making that is the exception not the
rule which is something I want to stress
it's so easy to feel like oh well of
course I'm exceptional of course
everyone thinks that everyone who starts
Amazon FBA most of them are looking for
a full-time income and of that so I
crunched the numbers for you guys so you
could see really the percentages I use
those same numbers and I just crunch
percentages of how many what percent of
those people are making it 8.25 percent
of people who start
FBI who are current active members will
make $15,000 a year that is pretty
terrible but let's say let's say you do
$250,000 in sales now you're getting
closer to a full-time income because
that roughly gets out to about $40,000 a
year 4% of sellers achieve this
only 4% guys 4% that is roughly because
I made a little fun fact sheet the
salary of a Costco employee for a
plumber they make about fifty five
thousand dollars a year to make that
equivalent with with Amazon you're
roughly gonna have to be making around
four hundred to five hundred thousand
dollars in sales to be making around
$55,000 a year assuming a 15 percent
profit margin now about two percent of
sellers achieve that and we just go down
the list because Amazon likes to tout
around a lot that it has twenty thousand
plus people making over a million
dollars a year with Amazon sales but
they don't tell you that 1 million
dollars a year in sales is really only
like 150 thousand dollars a year which
of course is that a lot yes but that's
not a million dollars a year it's not
even close and it just goes on and on
what you end up finding out is that uh
selling on Amazon like most things is a
per it follows a Pareto distribution
right it follows this distribution right
here it just slopes way down so with a
Pareto distribution assume that you're
going to be in this camp and then find
out are you happy with it are you happy
with being the majority where the
majority is not even making fifteen
thousand dollars a year that's the
reality with Amazon FBA if you join up
Amazon FBA you're probably not going to
make fifteen thousand dollars a year if
you do very well and you're in the top
10% you're probably making it up 15,000
20,000 a year if you do even better than
that and maybe you're in the top four
percent now you're making $40,000 a year
you're making what a Costco employee
makes at for the top four percent Amazon
didn't get where they were by paying
their employees a lot they got where
they were by being ruthless and slashing
costs everywhere they can so you can bet
that in the future they're gonna try to
shrink profit margins down as low as
they can so don't expect to be making
millions of dollars with Amazon
on that note because all these laptop
lifestyle gurus always want to talk
about Millions let's find out how much
do you need to be making millions well
you need to be roughly doing 5 million
to 10 million dollars in sales so you
can make a million dollars in actual
profit but you're only you have about a
point zero four percent chance of
joining and this isn't even getting into
the fact that a lot of these sellers who
do huge numbers are selling their own
product they're not f being from Alibaba
to Amazon a lot of those people have
private labels they're doing they're
making modifications to the product they
have a whole team guys the biggest thing
I want to tell you today is that this
really isn't the business opportunity
that a lot of these gurus are telling
you that it is there over representing
it to sell you a course and to get rich
off of you that's how they're getting
rich by the way they're not getting rich
from selling on Amazon they're getting
rich from you you're better off going to
start your own guru course than ever
doing this Amazon FBA thing I think
you're a lot more likely to make
millions doing that so anyways I just
wanted to give you guys that little talk
a little Amazon reality check so just be
careful know what you're getting
yourself into know the numbers I'll put
this spreadsheet up for you and yeah
thank you so much for watching talk to
you guys later
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
or the car
[Music]